polling stations have opened in parts of
India as the second phase of the
country's general election gets underway
one of the constituencies voting today
is in Srinagar the main city in
indian-controlled Kashmir a security
lockdown has been imposed on the city
where several parties have called for a
boycott of the election Kashmir featured
heavily in campaigning after a suicide
attack there brought India and Pakistan
to the brink of war in February a total
of 95 constituencies across India are
casting ballots today India's election
is taking place in seven stages over a
six-week period ending next month
let's bring in deed abuse Nimish Ajay
SWA she'sa following the elections for
us from Delhi Hina Missha
so kashmir really is taking center stage
in this second rounds a second round of
elections
well definitely so me it's not just the
second round in packets through the
selection that Kashmir is being talked
about very closely Kashmir
polling in Kashmir is happening over
five phases and they actually decided
against another level of Elections in
Kashmir because of security concerns in
Srinagar in the capital there's a heavy
deployment of security there's actually
a virtual shutdown and the city and
because the separatist calls to boycott
this election many voters are concerned
so far pulling turnout in Srinagar
itself has been low while another
constituency has seen a strong water
turnout push me teas are voting on the
one hand on the very strong BJP rhetoric
the BJP is Prime Minister Narendra
Modi's party to almost crack down on the
freedoms that Kashmir is enjoy as of now
a special status for the state while the
opposition says it will protect the
status so it's not just Kashmir is
voting for their own status all over
India voting will focus on the issue of
Kashmir all right so this has been a
central talking point in the lead-up to
the vote tell us more about this
election you know India is the world's
largest democracy and this is only the
second of seven stages of voting that's
right sue me every time India goes to
what in a general election it's the
largest exercise in democracy in the
history of the world essentially seven
phases and from the first year of
polling people will actually have to be
at six whole weeks to find out who the
- Prime Minister is going to be so
logistically it's a massive challenge in
debt the requirement from the Election
Commission is that voters should have
access to a polling station within a two
kilometer radius and with 900 million
people going to the vote that is quite a
task in itself this is the second phase
after five more phases may 19th will be
the last day of polling and just four
days later all seven stages of Elections
the numbers will be counted and we will
find out if Prime Minister Narendra Modi
will be given the National mandate again
or the opposition challenger al Gandhi
will be chosen by the country and
Nimisha you know we've also seen social
media really playing a big role in
campaigning tell us more about that
well Swami social media is definitely
essential because just coming back to
the numbers because this election is
about numbers you know just just by the
number of smartphone users have actually
tripled since the last general election
450 million users of smartphones in the
country right now smartphone penetration
has skyrocketed India has the largest
markets of whatsapp and Facebook and
even the Election Commissioners taken
note and for the first time the Election
Commission of India which is basically
the authority that monitors the election
is watching candidates online behavior
so candidates have to toe the line the
way they have to do in rallies and an
offline advertising for the first time
ever in India's electoral history we
actually went down to the southern state
of Karnataka to meet with one such young
candidate who heavily uses social media
to reach out to voters to find out how
he is appealing to the masses while also
ensuring that he towards the line that
the Election Commission is drawing this
is they just Vasudha he's a resident of
the South Indian city of Bangalore a
lawyer and an aspiring Member of
Parliament
at 28 he is the youngest candidate from
the ruling BJP to contest these
elections as temperatures soar about 35
degrees on this afternoon pages he goes
out of his way to greet and acknowledge
every constituent he sees each northern
wave is an appeal for works but despite
the palpable excitement of supporters
and party workers the politician is at
best reaching a few hundred over three
sweltering odds on Twitter pages we can
reach over a hundred thousand followers
in a flash most of a young people today
are hooked onto phones we are telephone
today our mobile phone today is a point
of both consumption of information as
well as entertainment
so our political with the greatest
political tool that we have today is the
small smartphone in our hands since the
last national vote smartphone usage in
India has tripled to a staggering 450
million election Authority is trying to
ensure free and fair elections have
taken note what's going to catch your
eye here is the colourful truck beyond
any which belongs to the BJP candidate
who's holding an election rally but no
less significant is this red card to my
right which belongs to the Election
Commission of India the Election
Commission closely monitors everything a
candidate does be it on rallies or in
advertising but for the first time ever
in India the next tour in history the
Election Commission of India is also
watching what a candidate does online on
social media platforms like Twitter and
Facebook
policing the worldwide web power is no
easy task
social networking platforms such as
Facebook which offer a high degree of
customization to their advertisers which
are again political parties based off
the personal information of its users in
actually reaching them so if what you
have is the perfect delivery mechanism
for political messaging in India which
makes it incredibly powerful but social
media can also be problematic
Dasia 3 has been criticized for all
tweets opposing reservations for women
and supporting the BJP s hindu
nationalist agenda he has even won a gag
order on the media to prevent reporting
on what he calls definitely allegations
but now a group of friends and
supporters is hard at work to boost his
online image the content is kept young
and peppy to resonate with Paige's face
persona political cartoons like these in
addition help directly establish Prime
Minister Narendra Modi's support for the
young candidate the social media team
must also ensure ethical content that
follows official guidelines social media
is a double-edged sword it works both
ways
we are really not in control of what
happens online it says at first user
base but whatever goes online from your
thesis fees account that we can control
supporters meanwhile a too exuberant to
be worried about privacy and fake news
but it is what happens online that may
well decide this election the so Nimisha
we saw there how important social media
is to candidates and to the parties what
impact is it having on voters also mean
many voters are definitely consuming
what's coming off of social media but
it's actually how discerning of water is
that's going to be a challenge many
waters are first-time social media users
and while the Election Commission is
watching that the candidate tows the
code of conduct line which is basically
not making communal statement is not
making hateful statements candidates
have the option of using proxy pH as
parties can be poor
fun's in two pages that are not official
pages and that's why the Election
Commission is not monitoring them
another challenge is whatsapp whatsapp
has end-to-end encryption so the
Election Commission cannot monitor what
goes out there but voters are often
susceptible to fake news that is widely
circulated on whatsapp so it really
comes down to how well voters are able
to engage the social media content that
not only the parties are putting out but
their proxies are putting out to make
sure they're making the right decisions
they're consuming what is being pitched
as the hopes for the future of the
candidates while also rejecting what is
clearly fake news all rightie reviews
nimisha choice for covering the ongoing
in indian election for us there in Delhi
thank you very much